the memphis grizzlies select job marin
university i love those guys with chips
on their shoulders and he plays the game
the right way
kind of came out of nowhere it feels
good
to be able to accomplish my dream how i
got here is crazy if you don't believe
in yourself then who will
here's moran turning on the burgers
wow
he is just must-see tv by the time he's
been in the league two or three years he
would be
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the season was my rookie year he's
nothing sort of amazing for him to come
out of
nowhere he's taking his team to another
[Music]
level
that's just too easy man
[Music]
jaw is more than deserving i think that
he should get this isn't even a debate
right now
[Applause]
so i grind every day my life is no
facade no mirage
sold out shows hold the applause that's
why i spent so many nights in that
garage
throws it down oh my goodness what a
pretty play
he took off runway style i'm a fan of
john moran
i know it's going to be doubters i feel
like i've been doubted my whole life
i just go out and play with this chip on
my shoulder i'm still not satisfied
this is the future
[Music]
you